say we got a hundred guys that come in
okay they're athletic but they've never
they've never done Taekwondo karate
they've never done Jujitsu they've never
done anything yeah and they come to you
okay and you're you're trying to see
who's a better fighter who's not all
Street Fighters and they've all had 20
street fights under their belt okay
what makes one better than another one
is it like is it are you able to Slow
Down Speed when someone's throwing
something are you seeing something
another person doesn't see I give you an
idea it's Sunday night I got a bunch of
people on my house I'm putting a party
two nights ago and we're playing Spades
on this table middle table I have them
playing chess okay and one of the guys
his name is Rodolfo Vargas we just sent
him in his dad and his uh father-in-law
to Qatar to see the final uh World Cup
just think he's on the flight right now
over there he's playing chess he always
beats everybody then the last table is
uh dominoes I don't know which one you
play they're playing dominoes chess
spades on this side
the guy that plays chess
you can think
with his eyes like if I do this and
India does this and he does this they
can go 19 moves or 13 moves they can do
that right in fighting there's got to be
some kind of an instinct a person has
that gives you an edge over another one
and they've never fought no instructor
nothing what would you say that edge is
natural
yeah that's that's control but when
you're talking about guys who come in
you know what he has 20 street fights
they
they already think they can fight and
they're not listening to instructions
you know so they make mistakes because
they only fought on the street against
the pro they got to have a problem so
it's the guy who listens and I said oh
tone this down a little bit and and this
is why you explode you know once they
start listening at footwork distance
again it's everything you know so that's
it are they able to receive information
and automatically do that right away
it's everything because you know you
have to tone them down because these
guys around their hot hats like also
guys with me I have the special stance
my stance is in wide open stance it's
like um Mike Tyson stance and um Ramon
Deckers who used to be the passed away
unfortunately created Starbucks in my
eyes
it's an open stance but it will make you
open here but that's it for the rest
everything becomes better more powerful
with blocking with kicking when
everything is better but a lot of guys
fighting in this stance now if they come
in in distance and they're knocking
people out they're not going to change
the stance because then it works if
they're fighting like this and but
they're not knocking people out still
doing really well then I will tell them
you know at the moment you want to knock
somebody out switch to distance because
it has got more power you see you start
coaching them and if they listen
immediately you know okay that's the guy
as guys come in who never did anything
and immediately they start listening to
your coaching those are most of the time
the guys who are going to make it so I I
have two boys and my boys 10 and 9 years
old I put them in Jiu Jitsu for the last
year and a half two years and just last
night I got home and I I wrestle with
these guys and I just trying to see
where they're at and let me tell you it
hurts right now oh yeah These Guys these
actually like Dylan yesterday got me
pretty good and he got me okay that I
had to really try to get out of there
ten and eight ten and nine what did he
have you with uh what was that a joke
had me in a choke yesterday because I
had his brother on top of him so I was
good with the brother my legs are locked
I'm good and then he came from back and
he got me a joke and I'm like I'm it was
pretty tight you obviously can't show
yourself and I was biting your leg the
whole sentence just kicking me I'm like
what are you doing son of my
six-year-old daughter but uh arts arts
uh you know like if you if you go under
the coach of John Wooden you'll learn
about beating your prior best John
wooden's not I think you can beat him
and let me tell you what he said about
your mom that's not Jordan wooden's
coaching style right but if you go under
you know Phil Jackson Phil Jackson is
about emotional control and then at the
same time mind games that Phil Jackson
plays where he wouldn't say anything to
your face but he would go to the media
and says you know you we have to see if
Kobe really wants to be won the best of
all time or not that's a decision he's
got to make and then the way he would
get you is through media right so you
would have a little bit of Phil
Jackson's DNA if you went under this
other guy you know so you would pick up
different people style so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got him in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]